the Joe Rogan experience ok let's talk
about the education because the idea of
free education is a wonderful thing for
people I mean the idea that you get out
of college and you're in debt in in an
insane amount that you might have 10 20
years where you have to pay it back and
and I know many people that are in jail
there are people who are getting their
social security checks garnished right
now it's not 10 to 20 years in some
cases it's literally a lifetime now a
lot of that is I mean it's got it in
some way be preventable by what we're
talking about here absolutely
all right and is that how you would pay
for it I mean how we'll tell you exactly
how would pay okay okay and we pay for
every idea that we have we pay for and
we pay for it by understanding that
today we have massive levels of income
and wealth inequality and we have many
cases the wealthy and large corporations
paying nothing or very little in taxes
here is the issue in terms of education
4050 years ago you're an average
American working class person you
graduated high school especially if
there was a union around you can go out
and get a job in makin into the middle
class you could own your own home you
could send your kids to school you
looked a pretty good life you made it in
the middle class 40 or 50 years later
there's an explosion of Technology
there's a growth in unfettered free
trade and it is clear now that most
people to make it into the middle class
are going to need a higher education
that's college or maybe it's technical
training in order to become a skilled
worker it is insane to me to deny
working class people and lower income
people the opportunity to get that
education because the cost of college
has soared so all that I say is that a
hundred plus years ago the American
people said that we should have free
public education I went to a public
school my parents didn't pay a nickel
went to kindergarten I went through the
12th grade pretty good education in
Brooklyn New York all that I'm saying is
the world has changed and a high school
degree is not good enough anymore so
expand that concept through college now
guess what fifty years ago do you know
how much the University of California
very great University cost in terms of
tuition
how much virtually free what's it now I
don't know but it's pretty high it is
how its thousands and thousands of
dollars so you had great universities
like the University of California City
University of New York state colleges
all over this country where tuition was
virtually free and then what happened
for a variety of political reasons
States and the federal government
started cutting back on higher education
and put more and more burden on the
student with higher and higher tuition
which is where we are today
so all that I'm saying is in the year
2019 2020 you have our working-class
kids are gonna go out and get the jobs
that are out there they need a they need
a higher education which should be
tuition free in terms of the
cancellation of debt which is my view
you got 45 million people um who are
dealing with that I'll never forget this
this is where I really hit me I was in
Burlington Vermont and had a meeting on
an issue and a young woman comes up and
she says she's a doctor she graduated
medical so she's very happy she's
practicing in a community health center
loves what she's doing he said Bernie I
gotta tell you though I am $300,000 in
debt probably gone to medical school I
couldn't believe it I was in Iowa a
young woman $400,000 in debt this is not
unusual for medical schools and in
dental schools and you know ordinary
people fifty thousand hundred thousand
dollars for going to college or getting
a master's degree we promised these
young people he said go to college go
out and get an education you'll get
decent paying jobs well the answer is
they have not been able to do that so
what we have proposed in one piece of
legislation or tool actually is to make
public colleges and universities
tuition-free cancel all student debt in
this country that will cost two point
two trillion dollars a lot of money over
a 10-year period we do this through a
tax on Wall Street speculation which
will bring in two point four trillion
dollars we bailed out Wall Street 11
years ago and by the way these are
crooks on Wall Street who engaged in
legal behavior
taxpayers against my vote bailed them
out if we can bail out Wall Street
we can cancel student debt and provide
public colleges and universities
tuition-free when you say a tax on Wall
Street speculation what exactly it will
be a tax on all of the every sale of
attacks you people buy and sell stocks
and bonds all of that we have a very
modest tax on it and by the way it will
have an impact on speculation by cutting
back on the high-frequency trading which
we now see so you would just there is
there's no current tax time correct so
you would put a small amount and that
would do the job that would that would
raise more than enough money it's a very
small tax it exists a small how much it
depends on the nature of the transaction
but it's less than one-half of one
percent really yeah because the yeah
because the amount of stocks being sold
bought and so and this is not again a
new idea it's it's being done in
countries all over the world what about
here here's one of the darkest things
about student loans is that if you go
bankrupt it doesn't matter
you still owe that and that that's kind
of crazy I mean if you have like a
serious medical issue if you're you're
held up whatever whatever happens to you
that's awful you go bankrupt most of
those things are resolved but not
student loans right I mean again this
looks through the and that has to do
with bankruptcy law which was passed
against my vote and while you're on
bankruptcy and actually I should have
mentioned this before when you talk
about the health care system a half a
million Americans every single year go
bankrupt because of medical bills they
can't pay but right with student two
this guy in Nevada never forget it guys
it's Bernie you know I'm open mikes if I
was in his fifties and he said you know
I've been paying off my student debt for
years I'm going nowhere because the
interest rates are high and I fear very
much which is the case that they will
start garnishing taking away my Social
Security checks taking money away from
me so people are carrying this burden
the result is that they can't
in many cases get married and have kids
they certainly can't buy a home they
can't buy a car they are really crushed
by this debt and what was their crime
what did they do they tried to get a
higher education I think that's pretty
crazy and a lot of them when
they do this higher education they're 18
years old imagine making a decision when
your brain isn't even fully formed it's
gonna affect you for the rest of your
life you've got it exactly right and you
talk to these kids so how much debt do
you owe um what kind of interest rate
shipping yeah I really don't know they
just told me to sign up VM
it's all right